passons en revue ce matin à l'assemblée
où chacun sait bien que les jeux sont
faits le ministre de l'éducation a
clairement fixé les règles du jeu la
titularisation volontaire des maîtres du
privé figurera dans la loi
si au bout de 8 la moitié de ces maîtres
n'est pas fonctionnarisé l'état paiera
si les communes s'y refuse
enfin des conditions sont mises à la
création des maternelles privées pour
l'ancien premier ministre du général de
gaulle
il faut que le gouvernement remette en
chantier un projet ambiguë les
délibérations du gouvernement
le travail du parlement la tension
l'opinion publique sont orientés autour
d'un texte dont la complication les
arrière-pensées et les difficultés
d'application sont l'assurance qu'une
querelle qui était apaisée fait
artificiellement ouvert artificiellement
grossit et va se poursuivre pendant des
années je peux prennent vie sous lui ce
projet n'est pas assez contraignants
pour progresser vers l'unification du
système scolaire
nous n'avons pas résolu qui est de faire
avancer les choses car si vraiment il
n'y a pas de volonté d'avancer
si vraiment il n'y a pas volonté qu'un
nombre plus grand enseignant un nombre
significatif d'enseignants de
l'enseignement privé choisissent la
titularisation alors naturellement avec
cette disposition prévue dans votre tête
chaussade actuelle ils resteront en
campant sur leurs positions jusqu'à la
fin des temps et ria n'aura bougé et
vous l'auriez pierre mauroy engagera ce
soir sa responsabilité
il annoncera une série de nouveaux
amendements
il ne désarmeront sans doute les
craintes ni des âmes des autres et seul
l'avenir dira si le point d'équilibré
recherché par le gouvernement a été
enfin trouvé